knights were the most feared warriors on
the medieval battlefield
they were highly trained well armored
and with their trusty steed
faster than any mere foot soldier
knights were at the top of the medieval
social ladder
and the subject of countless romances
and fairy tales
but where did the night come from and
what did a young man have to do
to become one
the first individuals we could
reasonably call knights
were the mounted warriors hired by
charlemagne the king of the franks in
the 8th century
these fighters were so important to
charlemagne's conquests
that the knights were given large tracts
of land for their service
this system of skilled warriors swearing
fealty to a king or
lord in return for land and later
titles was the origin of feudalism
the dominant political system of the
european middle ages
once the feudal system was cemented
becoming a knight
developed into a hereditary occupation
not just anyone could become a knight
while there were some rare cases of
commoners being knighted
most knights had to be born into
nobility
this was mainly because a knight had to
acquire his own armor weapons and horses
only the nobility could afford such
things
a young boy destined for knighthood
would spend the first seven years of his
life in the care of his family
taught basic etiquette from his mother
and other female family members
at the age of seven you'd be turned over
to a local lord
to become a page
a page was essentially a servant to a
knight lord or
nobleman think of the young boy in the
classic christmas carol old king
wenceslas
[Music]
along with his responsibilities as a
servant
the page would learn to hunt take care
of horses and in some cases
learn to read and write from the local
chaplain when he got
older he may have even been trained in
the basics of horse riding and
swordsmanship
though only using wooden swords
at the age of 14 a page would graduate
to a squire
a squire was essentially a night in
training
not relegated to doing menial tasks
around the castle anymore
the squire's main responsibility was to
carry and
care for the armor and weapons of a
knight
as well as accompany a knight to battle
carrying the knight's supplies
and his banner think of young arthur
from the sword in the stone
who at the time was a squire for sir k
the squire continued his training from
his time as a page
but would use real weapons and wear his
own armor
they developed certain skills that all
knights were expected to be proficient
at
these included riding swimming shooting
jousting wrestling fencing
and even dancing finally at the age of
21
a squire was eligible to become a knight
the young man would be knighted in a
ceremony called an accolade
the ceremony would usually take place
during a seasonal festival like
christmas or easter or even a wedding
the squire would have a ritual bath the
night before followed by a night of
prayer
on the day of the ceremony esquire would
swear fealty to the lord
or king and the king would knight the
squire by touching him on the shoulders
with a sword a practice most of us are
probably familiar with
a knight's main responsibility was of
course on the battlefield
they were obligated to fight in the
military campaigns of their lords
and show bravery professionalism and
chivalry
chivalry is a complicated topic and
deserves a video of its own
but basically chivalry was a code of
conduct that
knights followed on and off the
battlefield
in the modern day we think of chivalrous
behavior as a way for men
to act honorably towards women and while
that was part of medieval chivalry
it was only a fraction of what the code
meant but
again the whole subject is for another
time
lastly during peacetime knights were
expected to take part
in tournaments
tournaments were designed to display a
night's skill as well as entertain the
people of the court
the knights would ride around the castle
grounds parading their armor
heraldry and banner before taking part
in the military games
the events in the tournament were called
hastaloots
there were many such competitions but
here are three common ones
the melee which was a free-for-all duel
between a large number of knights
whether on horseback or off a tupenere
was a one-on-one duel where clean hits
to certain parts of the body would score
points
and of course there was the joust the
joust is the most well known and most
romanticized of the sports
it was fought between two individuals on
horseback holding lances
the competitors would line up across
from one another then
charge each other hoping to knock the
opponent off his horse
using his lance in the late middle ages
the joust became the main event in the
tournament
when a knight died whether on the
battlefield or off of it they were given
an
honored burial it was part of esquire's
responsibility
to ensure the night he served was buried
correctly
if the knight was part of a chevalric
order a sort of
nightclub which again deserves its own
video
they would likely be buried in the order
special cemetery
it was not uncommon in fact for knights
to join an order at an old age
as to ensure a decent resting place
it was also common for knights
especially very rich
or very respected knights to have an
effigy on their grave
a stone carving of them usually in their
full armor
so that's all we have for today i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did please give it a like watch
some of our other videos
and if you want subscribe to help build
the channel bye
[Music]
you